hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to an
edition of ask Evan weren't answer
questions from my readers today mansion
question from David Hurley who's one of
our forum moderators who wanted me to
check out his landing page so thank you
David and I apologize in advance for
being so late on this one they would
post this in June and now it's October
to take me awhile to get to this one but
hopefully I can still give you some good
advice so I loaded it up here this is
the page is promoting SFI affiliate
success handbook my immediate thoughts
looking on this is that the design could
be a little bit better doesn't have to
be fantastic or amazing but there's a
lot of even just using WordPress some
simple templates you can use to just
spruce up the design a little bit again
you're promoting something that is going
to hopefully make somebody a lot of
money so you want to make it look like
you know you're making a lot of money
from it as well and design can speak to
that so I know the better it looks the
more successful people are going to
think how you are with it so just a
quick thought on the design next thing
is it was presented by Ron Jackson so I
don't know who Ron Jackson is you know
I'm not in the SFI or affiliate
marketing world so maybe he's really
well known i'd probably have something
here with a link that i could click on
his bio to learn a little bit more about
him i'm assuming if you've partnered
with him then he he has some credibility
recognition so i'd want to showcase that
and talk a little bit more about who he
is just give me the option to learn more
about him i'd also try to find a better
picture again he may be a huge legend in
his field but the picture is not
fantastic again we want to try to if
you're promoting an opportunity to make
a lot of money the idea what the picture
is that we want to aspire to be that
person right so if you even just
comparing your picture here this is
David to Tehran's this is a little more
aspirational right it's a good-looking
guys on the water and Japan you know
travel photos this looks good this is
something I might want to you know be
like this guy this picture is a nice
smile but it doesn't make me want to be
like Ron Jackson so
to find a better picture of him and I'm
again I'm sure if you partner with him
he's very well known he has a lot of
great content I just try to find a
better picture so that people you know
want to be like him and have the success
that he's had as well so that and have a
little bit of eye on him also I put a
little more on you so you know I know
you David from the farms and you have a
lot of great content great information
and you've been an awesome member but
for people who may not know you as much
you know they want to have a little more
information on you're here to be able to
click on that and and some information
pops up your bio I may want to have a
video on there no it's been kind of
experiencing with with video a great way
to be able to get people to kind of take
that next step so I think about it talk
about the book of why it's so helpful
and why people should sign up for could
really help boost your conversions if
you do even a simple video that's
heartfelt and passionate and you explain
why you're so into SFI affiliates next
thing I try to look at is what is SFI
I'm you know people may not have heard
of it before you may only be targeting
people who are part of the SF 5
community which is fine in that case it
makes sense but for people who are
finding this on their own or through
links on the forms or wherever you're
promoting it it could be good idea just
to explain what is SFI why is it the the
secret formula making money with the
most successful free business
opportunity in Japan why is that suffice
so great what is it all about so that
could be in your quick video or another
quick link that explains what SFI is all
about with any workbook I always
recommend trying to explain what it is
that I'm going to learn so it's created
how to make money with all this business
opportunity the challenge here is
although I'm sure you have some awesome
content in here you're going up against
a lot of people who have really crappy
content and so how do you separate it's
good to show a little bit more about
what people are going to learn to
convince them to take that next step I
sign up now it's free so they don't have
to do a lot to got to go to that next
step but it's so recommend doing it is
way just to boost conversions again if
you can show a little bit more not just
promise whatever else is promising it
helps you stand out from everybody else
and shows that hey
actually really do have some really good
content and even as a quick example let
me load up one of mine so these are
worksheets that we put together these
are for sale but just as an example as I
go down here this is a screenshot so
this is the you know find your passion
helps entrepreneurs find their passion
for sale but will show them what it
looks like and we'll show them what's
involved in it so you can see you're
going to get practical advice from these
famous entrepreneurs here a few examples
Oh Bruins his advice to know if you're
doing the right thing or not so you're
not giving away anything I'm not I'm not
seeing what the advice is but I'm giving
little teasers so that people are really
curious I want to take that next step so
now showing how long this book is some
screenshots of it to let people know
that it has a lot of media value to it
and just high-level some of the things
that they're going to learn could be
very helpful without giving away really
any details about it so that hopefully
will help if i look back down here again
at the bottom two you'll also see that I
talk about myself so people who are
coming to this page may or do you know
me but if they don't it talks a little
bit about Who I am the media been in the
TV stuff that I've done so similar to
this great picture here who's David
Hurley so quick you know link to be able
to click on that and learn a little bit
more about yourself in the success
you've had with the SFI I also noticed
there's a broken image here so again
just professionalism you want to you
know clean up anything that's broken to
make it look as good as you possibly can
I love this review here this is great
five stars this guy named Joe that would
be good that maybe have a little more
information on here it's great that this
thing sells or thirty-five dollars and
you're giving it away for free so you
can click on tripleclicks and see what
this is all about just quickly so here
it is 35 bucks it's great for star is
great i might click on product reviews
and these are actually great so you have
ninety-one percent of buyers would
recommend this eighty-two percent it
would buy it again these are great
numbers you might want to copy and paste
this
and put it into your interior sales that
are here I didn't quite know where this
was coming from but you can say stats
from tripleclicks you know some great
testimonials I try to include these here
especially when you have one of a
picture picture of a guy picture of a
girl that's awesome put both of those in
include that below it adds more
credibility and you can also make this a
something that's clickable so if I click
on that it'll take me to the page here
so again it shows that it's a little bit
more legitimate because people and again
I I know I'm for those you're watching
David is a really you know reputable
stand-up guy but challenges your he's
going up against a lot of guys who are
not so there's a lot of skepticism in
the industry and people could think that
this is your something you put on
yourself all right so having that as a
link that you can click and you can see
hey there's actually somebody who left
this could add a lot of value so
hopefully that helped it's great to see
that there's a easy next step the call
to actions really big easily leave name
and email submit so that that side is
good it's great to see you've got some
good conversions already from this page
I think if you did some of those steps
so no more information who you guys are
slightly better picture slightly
improved design share more of those
testimonials and show a little bit more
about what SFI is and what they're going
to learn in this handbook maybe some
screenshots I think you could get your
conversion to the next level and
hopefully also include a video to take
it up a level higher so hopefully that
helped David sorry again for the delayed
response on making this video for those
of you watching if you liked the video
please give it a thumbs up below it
makes you want to do more of these
videos for you and if you have any
thoughts about this website or you want
your own website reviewed feel free to
leave it in the comments below I always
check out the comments it always makes
my day when I see somebody's left to
comment so please leave a comment and
I'll see you on the next episode
you